[Music]
cooperate and comply if you don't want
to die yep liberal cities ask you to be
polite and give your cash to thugs
without a fight
cops are warning of follow home
robberies in the pricey melrose shopping
district in liberal la you can almost
see the fear on their botox faces
a real housewives of beverly hills star
was just robbed of a million bucks worth
of valuables crooks lay in wait follow
you home and then bam steal the family
jewels so the lapd tweeted out a safety
warning telling people do not resist
robbery suspects and cooperate and
comply with their demands which sounds
like advice you'd normally hear from a
democrat
such a warning is expected in la where
crime goes with daily life like
kardashians go with butt implants
meanwhile downtown seattle
has gotten so dangerous government
employees need escorts to get around and
not the kind of escorts bill clinton
uses
a new program called the walking bus
provides king county employees with
security guards to and from
transportation private sector workers
however get squat as the seattle city
council proposed slashing the police
budget by another 11 million dollars and
back where we're at nyc incoming
democratic mayor eric adams recently sat
down with a blm leader to discuss
policing and crime adams to his credit
is reinstating a plan to put more
undercover cops on the streets and that
made blm angrier than jeffrey toobin
running out of kleenex
if they think that they're going to go
back to the old ways of policing then
we're going to take to the streets again
there will be riots there will be fire
and there will be bloodshed
but that kind of sounds like the status
quo right now and that's the problem
when things are this bad on the streets
vowing that things will be bad on the
streets no longer rates it doesn't
matter you're threatening us with what
we already have that's like the view
threatening you with stupidity
so congressman are you hopeful at all
that that the democrats are finally
beginning to see that they've been
incentivizing criminals i mean i mean we
have a no no
i'm hopeful that they would actually you
know see the lie today but they're not
going to we saw this with the virginia
election and we saw with elections
around the country you know
go when you when you defund the police
you shouldn't be surprised when you get
more crime except democrats they don't
care right you're just going to keep you
solved with the bill they pass so i
don't think they change what i do know
is the folks that i represent in west
central ohio they're not just going to
give what the what the bad guy comes
here they're just going to give in into
that they mean they actually believe in
the second amendment out where i'm from
so i just don't think that's going to
fly either yeah
and speaking of the second amendment
dagin
you know
the reason why rittenhouse became a
thing is because there was a void in
which the government didn't fulfill the
government in a sense the cowardly
politicians you know uh forced to reduce
the presence of police while the media
you know energized riots and so what
happened
an explosion of crime and then what
happens citizens have to deal with it
their way so what you're seeing is in
incentivizing not just of criminality
but citizens practicing the second
amendment right and you're probably
going to see paying for protection
because small businesses they don't have
any way of preventing uh shoplifting in
their stores but when did safety become
a dirty word when did safety become in
my bedroom
i don't even know what that means i
don't know what that means it's friday
brett i thought it was wait i thought it
was shoelace yes
welcome to the show
i've never been on one quite like this
trust me you'll get through it
yes i'm already looking at my watch up
right now
it's like a medical procedure it's a
little painful but in the end you're
glad you had it done
but safety's a how did safety become a
privilege and not a right and in terms
of new york city
you do that it is truly cooperate and
comply you have to lay down roll over
and be quiet you are not allowed to
defend yourself in new york city not in
any way the second amendment doesn't
yeah it doesn't apply to us so maybe the
supreme court rules on this case that
gets rid of the 100 year old concealed
carry laws here but it's very similar in
all these uh left-wing blue states but
that being said even if you try to
defend yourself somebody's going to
videotape it you're going to wind up
losing your job you're going to wind up
probably charged with the crime you
didn't commit so i've chosen to wear my
leftover frankenstein boots around so
i'm just going to walk around
and try to scare them
there you
go
that is a strategy
hence the exclamation point yes exactly
you know brett if uh eric adams stands
up to uh hawk newsom who from blm
the will the media then call eric adams
the new face of white's privacy yeah i
think that that's really an interesting
question yeah mayor-elect adams is a guy
a democrat who is
leading on a number of different things
including fighting crime and that is
popular that's why he won overwhelmingly
and i think you're going to see that at
different places around the country
crime is one of the most powerful
political movers of voters and if you
don't feel safe at home you are going to
vote the people who are not who are in
office that are not dealing with it and
they're you're going to vote them out
yeah and uh i think that that's really a
great question and i think it's going to
have to be addressed i think it's going
to happen you know cat how do you feel
about the advice from the police when
the for for people like you who go
shopping and spend
so much money on girly things that you
just that is what that is what i do
i think you missed one of the most
absurd parts of it of the warning which
said
avoid displaying high value items like
jewelry watches purses out in public
places basically what they're saying is
only wear your nice stuff in your home
alone
where nobody can see it
like i don't think that's why people buy
those things exactly what is
what's gonna happen to the wrap industry
brad if you can't wear your bling
exactly
yes
that's not what i thought you're gonna
ask him what's gonna happen that suit oh
yeah what was that suit it was a
christmas suit it was in the moment and
that was by the way
the real band oh i know i know that's
sugar hill right he'll gang yeah that's
amazing but it's still no excuse for the
suit okay
like you lost a lawsuit wear that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else